how is it being around Ichiro and griffy
man when I first got over here seeing
Ichiro I was kind of Star Struck really
yeah that guy till this day does more
than probably our whole team combined is
he out there often he's there every day
whole uni still does his full routine
he's out there shagging hitting in the
cage long tossing with Julio every day
making throws a second and stuff full
routine when griffy comes around do you
get to talk to him yeah for sure what is
something that he's taught you cuz I had
him in the WBC that info that I got
that's Irreplaceable the confidence you
know just how he walks around with all
that swag just no one's better than me
type stuff I think that's what I like
most about him is that why you tell
yourself be him pretty much yeah